welcome to bananamores nick go santos
just an electric comedian who will have
you laughing all day long
as you remember this hysterical set give
it up for nico
thanks so much mitzi ah you look great
did you get some work done
yeah i could tell i could tell good to
see you
ladies make some noise
insert city here how y'all doing good
okay
let's just get this rolling i've been
doing a lot of traveling
i know i just needed a change of scenery
so i took a little trip to my front yard
spent a couple of nights in my living
room i went on a shopping spree in my
closet
which i hate that place because they
never have my size my
boyfriend even took me to the hottest
restaurant in town
my kitchen didn't need a reservation
just walked in
food was great service was terrible well
actually tomorrow we're going to try a
new place called
paw patrol pose postmates
i don't know if i'm saying that right i
think that's it i'm actually
old enough to remember when you had to
call in to the restaurant to get
delivery
and i always felt really embarrassed
because whenever i called in to order
food
i would always always order enough food
for like 10 people
so i would pretend like i was having a
party
uh so it wasn't embarrassing so i would
call the restaurant and be like
yeah hi um we just want the orange
chicken
and uh broccoli beef uh-huh yes yes wait
hold on what's that what was that you
guys what
you oh you want some pot stickers too
what else and walnut shrimp okay
let's put an order of pot stickers and
mala shrimp because these people
are hungry i know yeah uh-huh
uh-huh no one set of utensils is fine
thank you
yeah that's it listen i
know i talk a lot about food because i i
love food
i do i love food um a lot of people ask
me what my favorite food is and i love
all types of cuisine
but my absolute absolute favorite thing
to eat
is my feelings i can eat it all day
it's okay i do listen i'm filipino
that's why i love food i can't help
myself
it's in our blood you know filipinos
actually greet each other by saying
which means have you eaten so you know
it's just
how we are as a people we're always
trying to feed other people
fun fact if you actually look in the
mirror and say
candyman five times a filipino mom pops
up out of nowhere and tries to force
feed you lactose
oh it already it
did i made that yesterday it's so good
just eat it food actually
saved my life one time it's true one
time i went to the eye doctor
and they were like listen is anybody
here to take you home because your
vision is going to be blurry and i was
like you guys it's fine i can see fine
don't worry about me i can do this so i
walk home
from the doctor's office and after
walking a few blocks
it happens my vision starts getting
blurry and you know what i was like
don't panic
girl don't panic you can do this you're
a grown man so i just
whipped up my phone i was like hey siri
directions to home please
and then siri was like
proceed to the root proceed to the root
i was like that is not helping that is
not helping
so i'm starting to freak out a little
bit because i can't see anything
and i you know i'm stuck there so i
called up a friend and i was like girl
you need to pick me up
i can't see anything and i'm stuck
somewhere and he's like well where are
you where are you i'm like
ah i don't know i think i'm in the
corner of so-and-so and so-and-so
and he's like that doesn't help and then
as if an angel heard me a breeze starts
flowing
and then i smell something and i was
like
hold up i know that smell i
know that smell and i follow my nose i
follow my nose
i walk left avoiding obstacles of course
i walk
left i turn around the corner and there
it was my favorite korean barbecue
restaurant
it saved me food saved me i had
daredeviled my way
to safety and that is why i am alive
today
thanks to food
that's my time thank you so much
doesn't get any better than this guy i
literally did not
stop laughing the whole time